it's 90 degrees Celsius I'm sitting in a
cramped dimly lit wooden hut with about
40 strangers and they're all naked the
first time I visited a nude sauna in
Germany I was way out of my comfort zone
but soon I noticed that nobody seemed
particularly interested in anybody
else's naked bodies in fact if anybody
was staring it was me simply because
I've probably seen more naked bodies in
that first half an hour in the sauna
than I had in my entire life
there were all shapes and sizes on
display and the full range of body hair
it was fascinating educational almost
visiting the sauna is a regular pastime
for millions of Germans but do you
really need to be in the nude to enjoy
this hobby a debugging focus for initial
[Music]
immersive our Isis monkey trash is neva
Clyde to his owner again dishes flashes
again Yashar by its metallic nema
understand copper and it goes to the
flesh ya around to listen women good wit
this is all no art by Aaron suburban
demand a meeting against entire public
done how does al Qaeda call Subedar to
Metis mechanic come on honey
sure it can feel pretty liberating to
bear all but the freedom is not absolute
there are strict rules that must be
adhered to if you want to be accepted
among the sorta clientele as a family
gathered by now the first rule is no
clothes
number two there must be a towel between
your skin in the sauna bench at all
times
rule number three no talking under any
circumstances sorry the highlight of any
trip to the sauna is the alpha plus
which translates roughly as infusion
this is the ultimate sauna experience
here's how it works you arrive at the
designated time and find the spot in the
sauna there are usually two or three
rounds which gets progressively hotter
in between each round you might get the
chance to go outside and cool down and
form an orderly knee
you for the showers kudos to anyone who
takes a dip in the ice bath
each alphys generally has a theme of
sorts the water ladled over the hot
coals will be infused for something like
coconut or eucalyptus if you're lucky at
some point little dishes of coffee scrub
salt or honey will be turned around
the sauna will become a hive of activity
as people slather their bodies from top
to toe in honey
sweaty honey an outburst is led by a
sauna master they keep order in the
sauna do the labeling and perform two
all-important towel dance to waft the
hot air into every corner of the room an
unmask sweat session in the nude if it's
not what you're used to
it sounds bonkers but don't knock it
till you've tried it